hey guys Ryan right in the hizzy Dan
cyber in the house so today we're gonna
check out the trailer for the highly
anticipated video game Star Wars
Battlefront
[ __ ] yes alright here we go where is it
all right it's the reveal trailer two
minutes and 12 minutes of Awesomeness
supposedly I'm so excited its
PlayStation I have one of those a dice
game
Wow
looks like
now
Oh
out
we
that's a chill Steve
Oh
I
I feel like I'm on smart let it
adventure huh stop that looks like a
total blast stop it
Wow dude um I love it it's like taking
from all the Star Wars movies and at
least the original trilogy it's like
you're getting direct sequences from it
this is [ __ ] Star Wars man you're
really in the Star Wars world it looks
awesome dude my brothers and I got
battlefront 2 for the ps2 way back in
the early 2000s or late 2001 ever was
and we spent an entire Christmas break
just playing that game non-stop I could
not be more excited about this [ __ ]
game right now that's the game engine
that's right it's a game engine right
when the trailers started yeah Wow look
smees you look so [ __ ] good yeah I
felt like I should have had 3d glasses
on it literally felt like I was on Star
Tours the whole time there's like this
is a ride right here and this is awesome
there aren't many times that I wish that
games have a 3d option on it this is one
of those games that I think I would be
totally okay if there was I would be
ugly on board for that this game looks
awesome and in 3d imagine being part of
this world we're gonna have a good old
time we're gonna be playing this and
then we're gonna go we're gonna get a
licorice in the way to go I see the
goddamn movie like I'm like later then
we mature each other off there's a kids
out so I need to shut up
god damnit try talking about jerking off
here kids knowing little [ __ ] sets why
do you take everything that's nice and
good in the world and make it about me
I never guys thank you for mentioning
those out if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the reel rejected
and you can check out Dan's gaming
channel
plays video games on there I will be
there on the channel next week just
giving you guys a heads up doing a
little gameplay with them and you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter
mmm where it is so much about revealing
the truth of what we're really like
really peel peel back the onions of a
YouTube we're really like dig in there
and kind of be like oh so that's what
they like they to eat Cheetos and put
their hand down their pants while
watching friends if you replace the word
onion with [ __ ] it would be this very
similar you know makes sense what you're
saying peel back the [ __ ] why do you
take everything that is good for me make
it about sex I mean sex is great don't
get me wrong
hahahaha sex is overrated I'm now I'm
now confused
that's not really worth it I've tried it
try to once turkey got though yeah
drinking office amazing you think about
whatever you want you know you got a
compromising sex
shabbu silly hmm hey Ryan bro love your
reactions man they are super hilarious
and kicks so much ass haha also Alyssa
and Sally are so freaking gorgeous and
it always gets me really turned on every
time they show up in any of your vids
hear that Dan Alyssa seriously how do
you hold yourself together whenever
they're with you man well Alyssa this is
just all over me all the time she really
likes me she's constantly telling me how
hot I am how sexy I am Sally not so much
but Alyssa she wants this yeah she's
with some with some like weirdo right
now dumbass yeah my girl you guys are
the best not can I please get a shout
out from all of you rejects or at least
whichever one of you guys are reading
this he gets it though yep she gets it
he gets it he gets it shabbu Celine
Shibuya Lee is actually a Kama Sutra
position did you know that no it's not
shabu silly is when you spread open the
butthole and then you put your nose
inside the butthole and then she farts
and then you get an erection
come on her face because you're cheater
holding her like like I haven't been all
around here you're holding her like
upside down a lot guys you're holding
her like upside down so her legs are
like up here and then you put your nose
in her butt and then then he come that's
what they call this Shibu silly